bienvenidos al puerto de Hamburgo el más
importante de Alemania
debería haber sido adquirido por una
empresa Estatal china pero finalmente
Berlín decidió limitar la adquisición al
25% en octubre
las inversiones chinas en Europa
deberían ser más supervisadas
china Está tratando de asegurarse En
infraestructuras clave en Europa lo que
podría permitirle influir en las
políticas económicas europeas y alemanas
de hecho Berlín Está tratando de
equilibrar la balanza bajo la presión de
Washington y sin querer ofender a
Beijing le gustaría evitar depender
demasiado de China económicamente en la
búsqueda de este equilibrio el canciller
Alemán o la scholls hizo algo inusual
escribió una columna de opinión en el
medio político y rock en la que reconoce
que la relación entre Berlín y Beijing
debe cambiar a medida que china
radicaliza su discurso hacia occidente
pero alejarse de Beijing es difícil
desde hace más de cinco años china es el
primer socio económico de Alemania las
empresas alemanas están muy vinculadas
al mercado chino
una imagen por ejemplo realiza el 40% de
sus ventas en China una tendencia que se
acentúa Alemania nunca antes había
invertido tanto en China llegando a los
10.000 millones de euros este año por su
parte china celebra las relaciones entre
ambos países
hace 50 años se establecimos relaciones
diplomáticas entre China y Alemania
China y Alemania son socios estratégicos
integrales
Beijing tiene motivos para mostrarse
confiado el comercio de Berlín le
beneficia en gran medida China tiene un
superávit de 40 mil millones de euros
con Alemania lo que representa 2.000
millones más que entre China y Francia
para muchos expertos el reto de Alemania
está claro aprender las lecciones de su
dependencia energética de Rusia y evitar
la dependencia del comercio chino